e nós conseguimos chegar até aos 50.000
likes Neste vídeo eu vou cortar vó era
eu vou cortar o meu iPhone 6 com esta
faca quente
o
doutor. É bom pessoal como prometido
hoje eu vou cortar o meu iPhone no
último vídeo que eu pedi para chegarmos
a mente dos 50.000 likes e nós
conseguimos chegar aos 260 mil likes por
isso eu vou ter que cumprir a minha
promessa aqui a cortar o meu iPhone Só
alguma metas Mas conseguimos atingir 1
milhão de likes
até termos um milhão de likes o corte no
braço com as patente está prometido que
eu sei que chegaram melhor vamos dar uma
não tenho dinheiro para comprar um
telemóvel livro tá sem a partir de um
iPhone que é caro para [ __ ] Pessoal
este telemóvel está tudo partido Olha aí
o ecrã tá todo relaxado e arranjar este
telemóvel sacos tipo quase metade de um
iPhone 7 novo e eu também está um pouco
avariado porque eu não consigo já fazer
chamadas nele e wallpaper tá sempre
ficar branco tipo eu ponho ou perder
tempo à toa não fica sempre Franco
sempre tipo atualiza sozinho eles eram
está servido muito e é por isso é que eu
vou cortar ali e vou estudar se por
acaso não é mesmo tempo doações
telemóvel vocês não iam fazer nada com
ele porque ele tá tudo poder ir hoje aí
eu percebi pelo tabuleiro ouija é pa
aqui no tabuleiro e e eu te falei muitos
comentários votos antes de fazer este
desafio e muitos de vocês me disseram
para eu ter cuidado com a bateria porque
ela pode explodir mas não fizeram o
corte né e ela fica mais ou menos aqui
assim Nesta parte esquerda e eu como eu
consigo abrir o iPhone eu vou cortar o
iPhone aqui mais para a direita só para
evitar uma explosão né já sabem pessoal
usar luvas que sempre Não façam isso em
casa não corta iPhone
[Música]
Bora lá pessoal OK agora é só aquecer a
faca né aí tem que arrumar o cartão
eu acho que isso vai explodir ser não
ser que a bateria explodir eu fico sem
mão o iPhone é tão bom que eu acho que
isso é resistente que salvará lá então
agora só precisamos é de aquecer a faca
que é o processo mais divertido né e eu
acho que ainda temos das né ainda tem
aqui Casting chocolate
[Música]
ou já tá começar a ficar quente
derreter um vidro copos tá chocolate
Ainda outra coisa pessoal eu tenho um
chocolate já preparado para fazer outras
experiências e portanto fiquem à espera
que vai ter mais experiência com o
chocolate é só deixar um like pessoal
deixe seu like vem um chocolate caminho
já sabe que eu vou comprar o que é um
daqueles livros que medem a temperatura
apontava a faca EA temperatura dela
encomendar isso hoje mas normalmente
aquilo que meter o limite bem tipo
Aquilo é feito para cozinha e tal e não
sei que não é que o médico para aí até
uns três mil graus só sem o esta faca
deve ir até os meninos que já não vai
ficar muito vermelho que eu acho que já
usamos a faca ela já está preta não eu
acho que é mais do fogo fogo frente tá
mais azul como tem mais fortes agora vai
agora vai
[Música]
e
ela não fica vermelha porque já está
tudo escuro lá do chocolate né Vamos
tentar agora mesmo assim
321 weiku pochete em
e
não faz nada porque o iPhone é região
Então por que não faz nada né
Hoje eu tô aqui mais a crosta que vai
sair vai gastar móvel estou tudo vamos
falar tudo por aí
ainda sendo
Amarelo
ainda funciona o
o ataque de secar ele estava em quinto
um
e o vidro está ter tido um pouco aqui
mas ainda funciona aparecer olha aí tá
regenerar O mãe o pai mandar
uma encomenda é isso é isso que iphone é
por tempo para [ __ ] iPhone ou e eu
fui como é que é possível funcionar
ainda não sei também
só falta a desaparecer em contato acho
que aqui já que é o momento que eu tenho
que fazer outra vez poder se Sorria O
meu é
E tu também serve o teste de qualidade o
iPhone se vocês quiserem telemóvel
resistente ao fogo resistência ao quente
resistente a faca quente resistente a
faca resistente a qualquer faca de
compra iPhone iPhone regenera queimadura
de toda a já voltou Olha vou por volta
outro olha o amarelo já que olha ali tá
voltar o quente mas ele explodir agora
agora vou concentrar aqui bem dava conta
e vou escutar a ponta no Iphone só para
ver que acontece 321 baixo e
e o
play tá porque amar é uma outra vez só
alguém que não consigo explicar esta
reação Diga aí nos comentários o que é
que vai acontecer o que é que eu tô a
queimar o porquê daquele líquido para
ali comentei a foto tá voltar acordo
para ver que ser outra vez e agora 54
meio de lado mas é que era bacana porque
era tu estás mesmo a faca assim com quem
for já Ai eu vou tentar esse a seguir eu
tentei ser toda massacre do iPhone mesmo
e tu nem me avisou o curso que
rebentaram está pronto já
321 bike e
e não faz nada o iPhone resistente de
tudo isso
aqui não faz nada né
eu não estiver aqui modo pois tá agora
sim pessoal eu vou espetar a faca com
bico quente no iPhone como vai força o
tecido uma ideia então um
e
não que o Marcelo vou dar a com martelo
em cima da faca e picareta ou pode ainda
pesado isso não preciso lidar com o
Marcelo mesmo em cima hoje é para
destruir tá pronto que estou vai
produção
321 acompanhei ou ou
oi oi
oi oi oi
olha aí tá tudo bugado
iPhone época em que indestrutível disso
não estraga ou ainda funciona por isto
cheira cheira tipo de caramelo mas não
sabe que ele cheira a novo sim só que
será ver agora está a chegar e conhecer
o novo master da velha eu escuto travar
caramelo tem a ver com isso daqui isso
eu eu chocolate nenhum vídeo assistir ao
que buraco aqui ele ainda tem a função
de ligar e desligar o
ainda funciona mas tem aqui muito bom
aqui olha que eu já todas alterada
[ __ ] vaca tá muito bom sentir um
calor da facul tu
e
o iPhone conseguiu resistir a faca
quente conseguiu resistir A um martelo
com a faca quente agora vamos ver teu
registo só o martelo
apontar e produção
Contagem vá
espera aí espera aí um
consertou Consertou o iPhone vai 321
meu Deus
fodeu de vez
partiu mais partiu mais parte mais
o [ __ ]
e
olha lá tá tudo bugado Agora fiquei
triste com o telemóvel da deep web meu
suave o iPhone ainda está a funcionar
mas eu não é mais forte do que nós vamos
conseguir destruir esta iPhone e vai ser
com a minha nova máquina de destruição
maciça e
e esta máquina tenho 12 toneladas de
peso sabe o que é que é de 12 toneladas
em cima de um iPhone tipo espécie de
entrar no iPhone não iPhone sobrevive
mais do peso não não ah mas já sabem
pessoal 100.000 likes nesse vídeo e eu
posto amanhã eu vi duas pagar o iPhone
já sabem como que eu vou se like fica
bem até a próxima tchau
[Música]